It might be helpful to cover
the basic types of relationships you
can have in a database.
Databases organize data.
And these pieces of data can have
relationships with one another.
There's one to one.
One to many, many to one.
And many to many relationships.
And example of a one to one relationship
is the user and the e-mail address.
We say one to one, because each
user has one email address and
each email address is
associated with one user.
At least in shopping list
plus-plus this is how it was.
If instead, we'd allow each user
to have multiple email addresses,
this would have been a one
to many relationship.
Because one user could
contain many email addresses.
Another example of this is
shopping lists and items.
Each item exists uniquely in
exactly one shopping list, and
therefore, has one
container shopping list.
But if we look at a shopping
list's relation to items,
it contains many items.
An example of a Many to Many
relationship is the relationship between
users and shopping lists.
If we didn't have shared shopping
lists and you just made lists for
yourself it would be a one
to many relationship.
Each user would have a collection
of shopping lists they own and
have access to and each of these
shopping lists would have exactly
one person who could add them the owner,
but that would be a pretty lame app.
Instead, each person has a collection
of many lists to have access to.
And each list has a collection of
many users that have access to it.
As you might example whereas a one to
one relationship is pretty easy to
show in your data.
And even a one to many relationship
is about as complicated as a list.
Many to many relationships
get a bit more tricky.
I've provided some links in
the instructor notes below
that talk in more depth
about these relationships.
When everything is constricted to tables
things get a little more interesting
than in our Jayson world with how you
represent things like many to one and
one to many relationships.